[موسيقى]
يحتوي بالتاكيد على الخبز واللحم والجبن
لكنه اكثر من ذلك بكثير البرجر يضم ايضا
مزيجا من الايجار والكهرباء والعماله
وسعره يعكس نسبه تضخم حول العالم مؤشر بيج
ماك يصدر عن مجله
ويقيس سعر صرف العمله على اساس سعر
الساندويتش الاكثر انتشارا والذي من
المفترض ان يكون واحدا على مستوى العالم
لكن الاسعار متفاوته بشكل كبير خلال تقييم
يناير ارتفع متوسط سعر في امريكا باكثر من
6% الى 5 دولارات وسته وثلاثين سنتا في
العاملين الماضيين رغم تفوق الدولار امام
بقيه العملات الكبرى خلال العام الماضي
لكن الوضع افضل في منطقه اليورو حيث زاد
سعر الساندويتش بنحو 15% على كل حال دعونا
نتعرف اكثر على هذا المؤشر الفريد مؤشر
بيغ ماك ماك علاء
منذ عام
1986 يصدر مؤشر بيج ماك مرتين في السنه
شطيره ماكدونالدز الشهيره تستخدم كوحده
قياس مبسطه ويعتمد المؤشر على حساب سعرها
في كل دوله بعملتها المحليه ويرصد ما اذا
كانت العمله مقيمه بشكل عادل او مبالغ فيه
امام الدولار بحكم ان بيج ماك شطيره
عالميه تضم نفس المكونات فمن المفترض ان
تكون التكلفه واحده او قريبه نسبيا لكن
التفاوتات الكبيره في السعر تعكس القوه
الشرائيه لكل عمله في سويسرا مثلا يبلغ
سعر بيج ماكس 6 دولارات و70 سنتا وهو
الاغلى في العالم بينما يقل سعره عن
دولارين في مصر ما يعني ان الجنيه المصري
مقيم باقل من قيمته الحقيقيه باكثر من 65%
طبقا للمؤشر لكن عوامل اخرى تتداخل في قوه
الاسعار بين دوله واخرى مثل معدلات
الضرائب وهياكل الاجور وما اذا كانت
المكونات بحاجه الى الاستيراد وغيرها هي
ليست طريقه دقيقه بالطبع لقياس قيمه
العمله بل مجرد اداه لفهم نظريه الصرف
بشكل اكبر مع ذلك اصبح المؤشر معيارا
عالميا ومدرجا في العديد من المناهج
الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا الصحفيه في قسم اقتصاد سمر
المشط عن الجانب الاقتصادي اهلا بك سمر
معانا يسعد صباحك دائما صباح الخير صباح
سمر ما هي الاليه التي يتم اتباعها لتحديد
المؤشر على الوضع الاقتص
ادي تقرير هو مؤشر حطوا الايقونه 1986
ليقيس الوضع الاقتصادي بدايه يتم تتبع اي
سلعه هم يتبعوا بيج ماك لانه فيها شطيره
بيج ماك من ماكدونالدز لانه فيها كل
المكونات نفسها بكل مكان في العالم فهما
يتبعوا هذه الشطيره بالذات حتى يعرفوا
الاختلاف في سعر صرف الدولار او العمله
وهل هي اقوى او اضعف مقارنه بالدولار في
دول مختلفه تقريبا 140 دوله تبيع البيج
ماك بس هناك مؤشرات اخرى تتبع الميني مارك
اللي هم قصتهم في الايبادز لانه ايضا فيها
مكونات وتباه بمناطق اكثر فاليوم تطلع
مؤشرات جديده تقيس هذه انه سلعه معينه ايش
قد سعرها باماكن مختلفه من العالم حتى
يقيسون صرف العمله وبنفس الوقت يقيسون
الاختلاف في سعر هذه
السلعه على مختلفه حتى يقدرون يقيسون
التضخم انه ايش قد ارتفع سعرها خلال هذه
السنوات لانه مكوناتها موحده بكل دول
العالم لكن على الرغم من كونه قياس معقول
في العالم الحقيقي الا ان هناك انتقادات
لهذا المؤشر من قبل بعض الاقتصاديه لماذا
لانه بالتاكيد يعني شطيره البيج ماك في
امريكا غير عنها في اليابان غير عنها مثلا
في سويسرا اغلى شيء لانه عندك هي لما
تنباع الشطيره يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار مو بس
سعر المكونات اللي هي تختلف ايضا سعر
العماله مثلا في امريكا اليوم من العماله
جدا غاليه في سويسرا البيج ماك اغلى شي
فوق الست دولارات ياهو اللي يروح يرجع
منصدم من هذه الحقيقه انه
السويسرا جدا غاليه لورنس الايجارات
المحلات ايضا العماله غاليه هناك عندك
ايضا هناك العديد من المواد تكون مستورده
يعني مثلا في لحوم تكون مستورده في مثلا
الخس يكون مستورد مثلا الخاص باستراليا
الان يعانون انه ما يقدرون يحطون خس لانه
ارتفع اسعاره جدا هوايقه ما يحطون احنا
نسميها اللاهانه او الكبدج ملفوف وصار في
اعتراضات انه كيف تحطوا بالساندويتش ملفوف
لانه طلع سعر الخس وبطله ويستوردوا هذا
بالنسبه لامريكا بالنسبه للمنطقتنا كيف
يؤثر هذا الرفع على سعر الفائده في
منطقتنا طبعا البارحه الفتره رفع سعر
الفائده
ب 25 نقطه اقل مره اخرى نعود الى مساله
التضخم اللي يقيسها مؤشر بيج ماك اليوم
البارحه بعد ما رفع الفيدرالي صار يدفع
الى 25 نقطه هذا الرفع كان ثامن رفع يجي
او تاسع رفع يجي خلال منذ بدايه العام
الماضي حتى يسيطر على السيوله بيد الناس
وبالتالي كل ما رفع سعر الفائده انت ما
تقترضيه من البنك او ما تصرفين اكثر على
كريدت كارد وبالتالي في محاوله لكبح جماح
تضخم اللي هو اوردي نزل الى خمسه في
ديسمبر وان شاء الله ينمون يرجعوا لي
الاثنين
اللي كانت قبل مشاكل كورونا وايضا الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وعصيره الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على فكره من ثلاثه ايام تم نشر
صور خصوصا على الويب سايتس العالميه
لافتتاح فرع ماكدونالدز بروسيا بعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي وبعد مرور هذه السنه كان
في طوابير كبيره عم نحكي عام 1990 اليوم
بعد 32 سنه و33 سنه تم اعاده اغلاق
افتتاحه وفتحت
تشينز مقلده لماكدونالدز
طلعت بروسيا مؤخرا غير الكوكاكولا التي
تتعامل لانه انسدت وهذا صح بنفس الوقت
يضغط على السوق ولكن يفتح فرص استثماريه
امام
للسوق المحلي بالفعل نادين احنا بنشكرك
جزيل الشكر سمر المشط صحفيه في قسم
الاقتصاد شكرا